[Music]
so I didn't feel to step back into the
ant-man suit I mean both literally and
physically yeah it was good it was fun
it was um Ben magining it for a while
and thinking of story and stuff like
that but to actually show up put on the
suit
jump on the ant it felt good it felt
good yeah you're all back is that any
modifications in the suit because it
looks different obviously yeah were they
ones you requested yeah no they were not
ones that well maybe a little bit it was
a bit of a hybrid between the original
ant-man suit and the one that they used
in Civil War and so it is a little more
streamlined but it has other options
there's a bit of a sliding scale or just
yeah I don't have to I don't just go
really really small ant size and giant
size there's there are in-between stages
and sometimes that happens when I don't
want it to haha and you can imagine the
problems that that creates I can only
imagine yeah I was gonna say is there
parts that are uncomfortable but
obviously there are parts that are
uncomfortable like physically wearing
the seat well yeah I mean sometimes it
it can get hot we're filming in Georgia
and so that you know but that's that's
mild that's the worst part honestly is
it's so thick that if I have an inch or
something it's a bit like wearing a body
cast and I can't get to it
you have you have like a real ant roll
on you it's yeah that's really good
problem and it's a knee
I can't just it's not like a t-shirt to
I can't just take it off so I have to
ask people to punch me to try and get it
so at any given time you might look over
and see some Michael Douglas punching
you Michael Douglas a grip yes somebody
anyway anyone who's kind of close by
like right there it's just and you have
to punch me hard yeah put some force
into it because you have a six pack
that's why no it's just as the itches
it's just it's thick the suit is thick
so when the rumor started about you guys
having an argument
no it's not true there's a lot of fights
on sex like you know he's just no he's
breaking out knives he's just getting a
[ __ ] scratched um the ant-man shakers
you are in really good shape but this
movie do you feel like now that you're a
superhero you have this pressure to
maintain a certain physique yes hey I
can tell you don't like it I don't mind
it honestly it's uh once you know once
you get into once you get into the
working out all in that kind of food
before you rush a you have you know it's
not it's you feel good you feel like I
sleep better and I I feel you know my
clothes fit better all that kind of
stuff and it's easier to do and you know
you're gonna be held accountable that's
true right yeah but it's the fans are
kind of crazy anyway once the once the
you know once the thing is done though
then something switches over in the
brain where it's a call cat can ease up
a little bit on the salmon yeah I can
have pizza instead of salmon yeah
exactly
I know your wife probably likes it the
six-packs oh you'd have to ask her
we've been together so long that's fine
it's like whatever it's just you know
Michael Douglas you know you get this
opportunity to work with such an icon
yeah um what was it like shooting
together it's the best you know he kind
of lends an air of authenticity to the
whole thing he's got such gravitas he's
such a great actor me that it you know
having him in there makes everything
better and getting to now work with him
two times and and get to know one really
kind of get to know the guy as crazy as
I am of him as an actor even more as a
person I just love him so much he's such
a nice funny smart and and and we get on
pretty well yeah you do I mean you guys
have some chemistry I must say and what
particular scene were you very
lovey-dovey towards each other right
without giving away the plot
well it's tender yeah it's a tender
moment between you and Michael Douglas
what was that was that was that a little
awkward in a way to have to shoot that
scene them and it was a very
entertaining for us of the Audion that
you know there was there were moments
where like we as an
you have to buy into the reality of the
situation and the scene and you you know
you pretend it's really happening in
real life but every once in a while you
do step out and look at how ridiculous
what it is you're doing is and and so
there were a couple of moments did you
guys say if you think what did you say
to each other and those moments where
you had to be lovey-dovey - I'd like to
think that I'd like to think that we've
now gotten to know each other well
enough that we didn't need to say
anything as we said it with our eyes you
did yeah it was beautiful moment yeah I
felt it yeah we all felt it as the
audience it was tremendous I must say
Michelle Pfeiffer how great is it that
she has now enjoyed the franchise you
and Michelle actually played lovers in
another movie first of all I could never
be your woman yeah now she's your
girlfriend's mother yeah was that a
little odd
no it wasn't I mean I was more nervous
but in the other one you know there
she's so cool yeah it was nice reuniting
huh it was nice seeing her again I
hadn't seen her in a few years and again
I just think the world of her and
there's something that you know it's at
work we're here making this movie and
it's really fun and you know kind of
action-packed and funny and
light-hearted and whatever it is but
then when Michael Douglas and Michelle
Pfeiffer
not to mention Laurence Fishburne like
we're unset all of a sudden it just
feels a little different it's like oh
yeah we're good wow there's some movie
stars on this is him big yeah and you
could tell too because even the crew
would kind of act differently there's
there it's it's hard not to be impressed
by these people but they also because
certainly Michelle and Michael and
laurence fishburne - they're they're so
easy at putting us at ease mm-hmm that
it just becomes you know really
pleasurable and not too intense or
intimidating for the rest of the day do
you ever sit there and go like wait a
minute okay Michael Douglas Michelle
Pfeiffer Laurence Fishburne all in this
movie but you're a man I never did think
that no you're the star no my thing was
I just want to become relaxed enough
around them and hopefully close enough
to them that I can ask them questions
that I just really want to know
Oh what do I ask I asked Laurence
Fishburne about Apocalypse Now you know
and asked him about Marlon Brando and he
was you know he grew up in he was it
well he's lived in the East Village and
yeah 81 so I said you know I asked if he
knew Basquiat he said oh yeah wait John
Michell right yeah he goes in and he was
telling me about how acting and art and
all of this in New York City at that
time was all kind of the same thing and
and so you know you when you get to work
with people and really get to hear these
incredible stories
it's nothing beats it yeah to talk to
Michael Douglas about Michael Douglas
has been in so many iconic films it's
true right yeah and he's produced them I
mean you talked to him about One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest to talk to him
about Stanley Kubrick and it's the
coolest thing in the world talk to him
about his dad Kubrick came back because
of pads of glory and so you know these
are not the things I don't start off
with them yeah but the entire time I'm
thinking oh man I really want to ask I
really I really want to I really want to
ask Michelle Pfeiffer about Scarface
computer you know I'm legitimately it's
really really amazing it's amazing it's
an amazing position and situation to be
in
and I know you are pretty cool dad I
mean being ant-man especially to your
daughter who I understand is drawing
ant-man all over the place
yeah she she's drawn lots of a man
pictures and ass now for years he gives
me new ones all the time I mean where do
you put them all well I have them I have
them all over would you like hang on me
your frame I have some frame to have
some hanging on the wall I have some in
a little file because there's a lot and
yeah it's it's it's really sweet it's
gonna make you feel good it's the best
she's like my dad is ant-man that's
pretty cool yeah it's not so bad right
let's talk about that the humor in this
movie do you think this is the humor is
off the charts that's so amazing like I
told you I think it's literally one of
my favorite movies ever
and just the comedy is you just can't
beat it do you think that's what they
did they did it on purpose it because
fans needed this after Avengers infinity
war that was never really the thinking
we didn't put that in mind I don't think
although maybe Kevin Feige who seems to
you know kind of know everything and has
this grand this big outlook on things
yeah oh that's an that might be a nice
sorbet after infinity war it really was
just that's kind of the tone of these
films yes it's the tone of the character
and you know in the first hand man I
believe we were trying to find it a
little bit how we didn't know how funny
do we go how serious do we go well
modulate it we'll figure it out in the
Edit I think there's an inherent humor
anyway I mean I'm riding around on an
ant
[Laughter]
let's let's draw attention to that so I
think it lends itself to you know humor
I also think it lends itself to maybe
being a bit more family-friendly because
I have a daughter in the film you know
the film is really about parents and
kids and so the challenge is making
something that works on many different
levels for many different ages and in
different genres because it's funny it's
hopefully moving it's really visual and
in fact and I believe we have our own
identity yet absolutely falls in line
with this Marvel Cinematic Universe I
understand you have a major part in the
next Avengers I mean ant-man does Oh
huge how exciting is this true I hope so
wait there's another Avengers uh-huh
yeah you didn't know this huh first time
here how big is that man's part ah we
want ant-man not to be small we want him
to be long
even though answer small but I like to
think it's not the size of the role good
answer
so that means I'm not gonna get the like
definitive answer I don't I don't know
what I can tell you I'm just gonna
follow me to win the ball all right
that's exactly it I'm just gonna follow
the lead of all the other actors that
have not said anything oh let me have
tis well we see you in more than five
scenes in the next Avengers it's
possible probably right
I don't know I'm trying really hard our
night it's really up to the editor
that's a good answer yeah and last
question
don't kill kill me but I haven't
mentioned avenged Evangeline the girl
power in this movie is fantastic yeah
yeah do you think that was like we
really got to see her do some fighting
of being you know some kicking yeah I
mean Evangeline is so great and wasp is
such a cool character I'm going back for
decades but certainly she's the one that
I think is much better suited for the
job really it's the family business she
was born into it and the character is is
really strong and tough and it is day
and age and and so does Evangeline
absolutely it's a really cool thing to
be in the first Marvel movie that has a
female superhero mentioned in the title
yeah you Marvel's been doing this for a
while there are plenty of female
superheroes that are tough and cool and
amazing powerful but to have the to be
in the movie where one is in the title
that it's my partner and we also have a
female villain which is
pretty cool yeah it is yeah it says
don't see there's some new there are
some things that are that are they're
kind of refreshing I think in this film
I just noted your little pin digging it
who gave you the add Michael Fisher oh
really
yeah Michael Fisher Industries how cute
that looks awesome
thank you thanks Michael